Reading is powerful in how it
forms our brain, how it helps
us acquire new languages.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here again,
and today I want to talk about reading
because the last time I spoke about
listening, uh, remember though, if
you enjoy my videos, please subscribe,
click on the be for notifications.
If you follow me on a podcast
service, um, please leave a comment.
So I spoke about listening
and how powerful it is.
Podcast service, you know, so many
ways that we can listen today, how
throughout the history of time, uh,
listening has been a major way or
the major way whereby people learned,
learned from others, were entertained,
acquired knowledge, communicated.
Listening was the key.
Reading is relatively recent.
Um, I don't know.
I don't remember exactly.
You know, people first started writing.
We have, uh, Chinese turtle shell
script if I remember correctly from my
Chinese history, we have cuneiform the
scripts, uh, you know, in, in old Elam
and Sumer and the Akkad and Mesopotamia.
Again, my knowledge of history is fuzzy.
Fuzzy knowledge is good until you
have to write exams because you're
gradually getting a clearer and
clearer picture of these things.
And even when you think you've firmed
up, you know, you remember the actual,
you know, date of the, uh, ruler of
whatever in, uh, ancient something
rather pretty soon you forget it.
So it doesn't matter.
So vaguely, uh, I think the first
writing took place somewhere
in the fertile Crescent.
Uh, and, uh, I think the original,
you know, purpose of writing was
to keep track of, you know, for
accounting purposes, keeping track
of the grain that was in storage
and it helped to administer things.
And then there is the famous, um, Darius's
declaration of human rights, which
was written using a cuneiform script.
And I believe it was written
in, not in Persian, but in, in
the language of Elam or Akkat.
I just don't remember.
As I say, my history knowledge is
very fuzzy, but I have a vague...
and the vague, I, I always feel by
the way, this gets me to reading, you
know, Whenever we're told to read in
school, we're asked questions about
our understanding and I always resist
these listening comprehension questions,
or reading comprehension questions.
I like having an imperfect
knowledge of what I read.
If I enjoyed what I read, if I found
it interesting if I understood many
parts of it, but didn't understand
some other parts and I can't remember
the exact date of this or who did
what to whom, it doesn't matter.
It was still enjoyable to me.
I liked reading for enjoyment, but
starting back whenever it was 2,500,
3000 years ago, when the first people
started writing for whatever purpose,
uh, up until basically the popularization
of, uh, of, um, you know, printing
in the 15th century, um, and even
thereafter, most people didn't read.
So the brain, which is, you know, from
an evolutionary perspective has had
a lot of experience at listening and
deciphering meaning from listening.Hasn't
had very much experience or exposure
at, uh, dealing with writing.
And it's quite amazing to me that you
can have lines on a piece of paper,
uh, whatever the script may be.
It doesn't matter whether it's the
Latin script or whether it's Chinese
characters or whether it's the, uh,
you know, Persian script or Hangul.
It doesn't matter.
You've got lines that are converted by
the brain into meaning sometimes also in
most cases, in fact, converted into sound.
So the brain has to do this processing,
which, which is a tremendous feat
for the brain to do, because it was
something that the brain was not, you
know, prepared to do over the hundreds
of thousands of years that, that
human beings and the predecesors have
been wandering around on the earth.
And so I enjoy reading, uh, you know,
right now I'm reading a German book.
A German book about the
Austro-Hungarian Empire, which is
where my parents were born actually.
And to, to sit in bed with a book,
even if I'm reading on my iPad, which
I like to do, because I can look up the
odd word in German that I don't know.
Uh, it's cozy.
I don't want the sound.
I don't want the audio.
I just want the written word to connect
with that written word because the
written word conjures up the meaning
in a different way from listening.
I mean, in a way the
written text is a record.
It's a record just as the
audio is a record, but it's
a different kind of record.
And I'm not a neuroscientist so I don't
know whether different parts of the
brain process the writing, as opposed to
the audio to convert them into meaning.
But I am convinced that doing a
lot of reading as well as listening
helps in acquiring languages.
I've said before, If I just hear the
sound of a new language, I can almost
not make out the sound, but if I get a
phonetic version of that, and in the case
of a non phonetic script, like Chinese
characters, I, I would use the opinion,
but it helps to define that sound.
And gradually I get better at hearing
that sound, but I rely on the written
script in order to decipher the sound.
Uh, and I, I think this is true of
everyone and we see how people very
often are influenced in how they
pronounce a word in another script.
If say, say using the Latin alphabet,
if someone is say check and they read
something in English, or if they're a
Spanish speaker and they read something
in English, they will be influenced by
how, what the letters mean, how they
are pronounced in their native language.
And that'll be reflected in how
they pronounce the new language.
So they're obviously not relying
entirely on hearing the sound.
They are very much
influenced by their habit.
You know, their reading habits and
what the value of the, of those letters
are in their own writing system.
So reading is powerful in how it forms
our brain, how it helps us acquire
new languages, and it's pleasant.
It's a different experience.
I can sit with a book and
read for two, three hours.
I can't sit, just sit and
listen for two, three hours.
I lose concentration.
I get restless.
If I'm in my car listening, that's fine.
And the great advantage of listening
of course, is that it's so portable.
You can be doing other
things while listening.
You can sort of fade in and
out while listening, cuz you're
also doing something else.
You're kind of happy.
Whereas when you're reading.
If you fade out, you kind of have
to reread the sentence again,
because you're kind of more focused.
At least that's my own
experience, more focused on the
meaning when you're reading.
And so reading other than the
fact that it's the fastest way to
acquire in acquire information.
If I, if I need to instructions on how
to fix my, uh, coffee maker or something.
Like, or if I look up, uh, something
on the internet, uh, having to do with
the, I don't know, recharging my iPhone,
I prefer to read because it's faster.
I can select, I can
jump from spot to spot.
I can, I can get that
information more quickly.
If I have to listen or watch
through a video, then I'm kind
of at the mercy of whoever is
speaking or producing the video.
Whereas if I'm reading,
I control where I go.
Uh, similarly with a book, if I wanna
skip this chapter or jump ahead or
behind, and I know exactly where I want
to go to, I can skim the pages and see
those areas that are of interest to me.
So reading is a, is, is quite a different
experience, but reading is powerful.
I've said before I consider with a
new language, when I have read a whole
book paper book, without a dictionary
without the iPad, from cover to cover.
I consider that to be a major milestone.
I am far from being able to do that
in Persian or Arabic, because I'm
not comfortable enough with the
script, but, uh, even in Polish,
which I don't speak well at all,
I can make my way through a book.
I know enough words.
And of course the writing
system is familiar to me.
So, uh, an obstacle when we're learning
languages, where the writing system
is different is that you can't make
up for, in my case, uh, 70 plus years
of reading in the Latin script and
expect that a couple of years of
reading in the, uh, in the Arabic
script is gonna give me the same
degree of familiarity with that script.
And yet I know that if I, if I
wanna progress in Persian or Arabic,
I have to get better at reading.
Reading is a major, you know,
again, source of enjoyment, but
also a major learning activity.
And some people say
they don't like to read.
All I can say is try to develop
the habit, start reading
things of real interest to you.
Obviously don't take on a classic
of, you know, French literature, if
that's not of interest to you read,
uh, comics read things on sports.
Uh that's I think where anime in the
case of, uh, people interested in
Japanese is kind of like cartoons,
read comic books, whatever you like
to read, develop that reading habit.
Get the brain used to reading used
to converting meaning from written
text, because it's gonna be a
major, major advantage, uh, in life.
Uh, professionally, academically,
whatever, but also in terms of
language learning, it's, it's
a powerful, powerful activity.
So as you know, I'm very much in favor
of input based learning, build up your
potential through reading and listening.
And when you have the opportunity
to speak, speak, but don't
neglect reading, it's powerful.
Anyway, I've done videos on the
subject before so I'll leave a
few here for reference for you.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.